so are you watching The Last of Us I
know I know pretty much everyone is I
wasn't sure what to expect the cast to
be like when they're not fighting for
their lives during the apocalypse or how
they feel about their once in a lifetime
roles Pedro Pascal was apparently a
no-brainer for Neil druckman they wrote
and directed The Last of Us video games
and co-created the HBO adaptation Neil
said that they had their eyes on Pedro
because we knew we would make a mistake
if we cast a purely tough guy as Joel
Pedro can play tough for sure but he's
got way more Dimension depth and heart
than your classic action hero apparently
the feelings that Pedro was made for the
role were mutual dude was cast as Joel
the same day he read the script and if
it wasn't already clear that he was the
perfect choice for Joel his
record-breaking Rotten Tomato streak has
only gotten better literally every main
character that Pedro's played on a TV
series has been above 89 on Rotten
Tomatoes and The Last of Us is at a
whopping 99 I felt like I could see a
real bond between him and fellow Game of
Thrones Alum Bella Ramsay you know the
one who plays Ellie and I gotta say
Bella Ramsay is the perfect Ellie to
Pedro's Joel and credit to Neil Brookman
because he did what he could to make
sure of that he watched over a hundred
actors auditions for Ellie before it was
Bella's turn and he'd said it didn't
feel like I was watching someone acting
like Ellie I was watching Ellie and
honestly I couldn't agree more and Bella
doesn't just fit Ellie to a t Ellie has
changed to fit Bella too Bella's had
some awesome suggestions for details
about her character Ali sleeping with a
switchblade the first night she spends
with Joel and Tess was all Bella and
Tess was deaf a fan of working with
these co-stars too anatorev did have her
work cut out for her as Tess like she
absolutely nailed taking on that complex
character didn't you find the actor
actually said they were encouraged to
give their own interpretations of the
characters instead of just going with
what the characters were like in the
game it's a new interpreter Anna
definitely didn't mind this she was
actually kind of relieved and she wasn't
restricted and got to create her own
version of the character oh and someone
else who Dove right into building their
character the one and only Gabriel Luna
so you might remember Gabriel from
Marvel's Agents of Shield and while he's
playing Tommy now it seems like he's
feeling pretty great about it why well
he just happened to be a big fan of the
games and the character Tommy how about
that for a coincidence and as someone
who knew the games Gabriel got really
into it and it was pretty cool for him
because he got to have fun with new
insights about what happened before the
story told in the game now that's a game
Lover's Dream I think yeah oh gosh and
Nick Offerman it was actually his wife
Megan Mullally we gotta thank for
getting him in the show Parks and Rec
daff knew who he is but what's crazy
here is that he didn't actually have
time between other projects to take on a
role when he got the script for the
third episode the last of us but luckily
his wife Megan had read it and knew it
was too good to miss and like thank
goodness because she was right by the
way learning that he'd be performing in
the heartbreaking episode across from
the White Lotus star Murray Bartlett
seriously only sweetened the deal duh
Nick had actually said that he got the
news just after finishing the White
Lotus season one if I don't see 2022
Emmy winner Murray Bartlett back on the
award stage this year for his role as
Frank I am rioting who's in Frank was a
character in The Last of Us games but it
wasn't nearly as big of a part the
series took a totally different path
with Bill and Frank's story and no one
could have fleshed out the character
better than Marie I'm totally not
surprised that Marie's partner also had
a strong reaction to the episode like
didn't we all connecting with this
character was so special for him which
is probably the right word to use when
it comes to Merle Dandridge too
she has a pretty interesting
relationship with her character Marlene
she's actually the only character who
reprized her role from the game in the
series so like how did this work well
according to executive producer Craig
Mason Merle was a bit younger than her
character when she first did it while
the other actors were closer to their
character ages so after those few years
most of them aged out but Merle she's
the perfect age to embody her now Merle
said that getting to truly embody the
character she originated was both
surreal and nerve-wracking would you be
feeling the pressure if it was you oh
and pressure did Nico Parker feel none
she really kicked the series off with
her portrayal of Sarah while she
definitely knocked the heart-wrenching
role out of the park for well obvious
reasons Nico was nervous about bringing
a character that was already so loved by
fans to life in a new way but with her
performance I mean I was a fan and oh my
gosh let me fan girl for just a sec
Melanie Linsky plays Kathleen what a
queen okay so if you're a fan of the
games and you're wondering who exactly
Kathleen is that's because she's
actually a new character introduced just
for the series from her roles in Castle
Rock to the hit series Yellowjackets
it's really no wonder why anyone would
want to cast her but for the co-creator
Craig the Emmy nominee is also a friend
and according to Melanie she and Craig
co-hosted Zoom Mafia games during the
covid lockdown and Melanie knew she was
in good hands with the creator of HBO's
award-winning series Chernobyl too which
that's fair okay but she wasn't the only
one that played a totally new character
though Jeffrey Pierce plays Perry
another character made for the series
but Jeffrey himself wasn't new to the
world of The Last of Us yeah Jeffrey was
actually the voice of Tommy in the video
game and did the motion capture for the
character so if he recognize his voice
from somewhere other Than The Last of Us
game it's probably actually from Call of
Duty
okay but are you loving the last of us
which character is your favorite so far
let's talk about it in the comments